[Musik]
[Applaus]
freunde der sonne alle reden immer nur
von zucker aber was ist eigentlich mit
salz passiert wenn wir zu viel salz
essen kann mir nicht vorstellen und das
ist gut für die organe ist wo ist salz
überall versteckt wie viel sollte man
eigentlich essen und geht das überhaupt
da schmeckt halt gar nicht darum geht es
heute und wir fangen direkt bei euch an
hier oben in der infoguard findet ihr
ein paar fragen zum thema salz die
richtigen antworten gibt es im laufe des
videos jetzt beantworten nicht schummeln
und tue ich mich nicht außerdem wollte
ich jetzt schon wissen was die leute da
draußen zu sagen haben aber da ich
erkältet war habe ich meine lieblings
reporterin saadet losgeschickt hallo
liebe may hallo liebe freunde der sonne
hallo sage ich bin saadet und ich bin ja
heute an der uni mainz um herauszufinden
was die studenten zum thema salz zu
sagen haben hat nicht schon davon gehört
dass zu viel salz und gehirn ist ja echt
noch nicht in zu großen mengen läuft
also ich sag mal so ich habe schon
mehrmals gehört halt auch so mama so nah
zu viel salz nicht nur verkäufer aber
ich liebe sein
aber warum liegen wir salz dazu müssen
wir erst mal durchgehen was salz genau
ist chemiker verstehen unter salz ganz
allgemein eine in verbindung im alltag
meinen wir mit salz auf ein ganz
bestimmtes salz natriumchlorid
oft gibt es auch jodsalz da ist ein teil
des natriumchlorid durch natrium ionen
ersetzt wallroth wichtig ist für unsere
schilddrüse aber heute geht es weder um
spirit noch ums geld sondern um das
natrium natrium ist ein metall das ihr
wahrscheinlich noch nie in echt gesehen
habt es sei denn ihr habt zufällig mal
damit im labor gearbeitet es ist so
weich dass man es mit einem messer
schneiden kann und es reagiert heftig
mit wasser und gerade weil es so reaktiv
ist kommt es in der natur als metall gar
nicht vor sondern immer nur als positive
natrium ionen natrium ionen sind also
und reaktiv und damit erstmal nicht
giftig im gegenteil sie sind
überlebenswichtig die regeln nicht nur
unseren wasserhaushalt sondern sie
spielen auch eine wichtige rolle bei der
kommunikation unserer nervenzellen
bei der verdauung beim knochenaufbau und
viele mehr weil wir täglich über unseren
urin und über unseren schweiß salz
verlieren und unser körper kein eigenes
salz neu bilden kann müssen wir das salz
über unsere nahrung aufnehmen könnt
genau das ist der grund warum wir salz
lieben nämlich damit wir auch genug
davon essen aber genau wie bei zucker
ist es heutzutage kein struggle mehr
genug salz zu bekommen im gegenteil wir
leben im herzhaften überfluss und was
passiert jetzt wenn wir zu viel salz
essen weiß ich und hat sogar auch
mitbekommen was da so die nebenwirkungen
von sind nein hab ich noch nicht kann
mir nicht vorstellen das ist gut für die
organe ist in vibration flüssigkeit
hinzu oder so es stimmt salz heißt
erstmal wasserverlust aber warum der
salzgehalt in unserem körper wird über
unsere nieren geregelt das heißt
überschüssiges salz pinkeln wie einfach
aus das führt einerseits dazu dass die
salzkonzentration im urin erhöht wird
andererseits aber auch dazu dass wir
generell mehr pinkeln um die menge an
salz herauszuspielen dadurch verlieren
wir viel wasser deshalb immer genug
trinken freunde der sonne genug trinken
klingt ja einfach aber salz macht noch
etwas anderes die natrium ionen gelangen
auch ins blut und wenn dort die
konzentration steigt möchte der körper
das ausgleichen indem er die
konzentration durch meerwasser wieder
verdünnt mehr wasser bedeutet ein
höheres blutvolumen und damit ein
höherer blutdruck kurzfristig kann der
körper hohen blutdruck ganz gut händeln
aber langfristig führt ein erhöhter
blutdruck zu herz-kreislauf-erkrankungen
die nummer eins todesursache in
deutschland sowie zu den langfristigen
folgen aber kann man auch an einer
einzigen überdosis salz sterben
vielleicht schon ja auf jeden fall dass
das nicht dieses osmose dinklage da
wirst du wirklich so löffelweise sich
reinzustopfen ist vor allem bei
kleinkindern scheint das sehr gefährlich
kochsalz liegt die tödliche dosis genau
genommen die mittlere letale dosis bei 3
gramm pro kilogramm körpergewicht bei
mir wären das 150 gramm salz so viel
müsste ich jetzt auch
einmal zu mir nehmen das passiert einem
zumindest schon mal nicht aus wir sehen
doch bei babys oder kinder die eben
nicht so viel wiegen kann es deutlich
gefährlicher sein so gab es 2005 den
tragischen fall eines kindes das an
einem versalzen den pudding starb und
auch erwachsene sollten salz ernst
nehmen da hätte ich schon mal von dem
trick gehört eine konzentrierte
salzlösung zu trinken um davon zu
erbrechen
das ist bei uns so sechsmal auf dem dorf
ist es so ein geläufiges für
mittelfristig soll ich mal so diese dorf
weisheiten also wenn man halt zum
beispiel zu viel getrunken hat und es
geht eigentlich gut und so dass man
glaube ich warmes salzwasser trinken
sonne oder wasser mächtig viel salz halt
weil das halt den magen nicht gut
bekommt und dann musst du davon durch
übergeben also davon hat schon mal
gehört ich hab's gemacht und das sollte
die auch nicht machen salzlösungen
trinken schmeckt nicht nur scheiße es
ist auch richtig heiß im gegensatz zu
kleineren kindern werdet ihr
wahrscheinlich nicht sofort sterben aber
natrium spielt in unserem körper eine so
wesentliche rolle dass selbst eine
einmalige akute vergiftung den körper so
dermaßen aus der bahn werfen kann dass
menschen schon an den folgen gestorben
sind salz ist gut aber wie viel salz
darf man denn jetzt essen die offizielle
empfehlung der whu bzw der deutschen
gesellschaft für ernährung liegt bei 6
gramm salz pro tag das ist ein
schnapsglas und so viel sex com salz
anderthalb teelöffel sind dass ich
glaube ich es viel mehr salz pro tag
würdest du sagen ist er ein bisschen zu
vielseitig letzte definitiv zu viel
selbst bin halt auch semantisch meist
auch ordentlich ums essen ran also so
möchte sein doch total gern mag hab hier
weil meine nudelwasser kommt auf jeden
fall ordentlich sei freilich dass das
bei anderen leuten die in keine ahnung
aus thailand oder so gekommen sind die
haben gesagt das hier soll sich nicht ab
dann immer gedacht merke ich jetzt
eigentlich gar nicht so dass ich glaube
die sind ziemlich dieses salz essen
gewohnt also ich vermute er
und sich gar nicht salzarm ernähren kann
es sei denn man kocht jetzt alles selbst
ich gucke neuerdings nämlich seit 2016
muss der salzgehalt von lebensmitteln
auf der nährwerttabelle mit aufgeführt
sein
und es ist ziemlich überraschend wenn
man mal da genau drauf schaut hättet ihr
zum beispiel gedacht dass in einer
tiefkühlpizza meistens mehr salz ist als
in einer ganzen tüte chips oder dass
manche confixx orden ganz schön viel
salz enthalten 1,12 gramm pro 100 gramm
und auch und vielen anderen vor allem
schokoladigen süßigkeiten steckt einiges
an salz unter allen lebensmitteln ist
die haupt aufnahme quelle von salz roth
ja ich war überrascht im schnitt steuern
droht knapp 30 prozent der tageszufuhr
bald je nach brot können dass bis zu 50
prozent seien kein portugal in holland
wurden deswegen sogar gesetzliche
grenzwerte für salz in brot eingeführt
aber ist man auch automatisch weniger
salz wenn man selbst kocht ich mache den
tomaten saucen test 100 gramm fertige
tomatensoße enthalten circa 1,6 gramm
salz ich nehme 100 gramm passierte
tomaten unter schmeckt halt gar nicht
und geben nach und nach 200 milligramm
portionen salzen zu bis ich finde dass
es schmeckt ja hier sind jetzt 14 gramm
salz auf 100 gramm tomaten sauce drin
es schmeckt noch nicht gut weil noch
keine anderen gewürze drin sind aber ab
jetzt finde ich selbst schmeckt salzig
im zweiten besuch wird sich die
tomatensoße ordentlich mit allem ausser
salz und wiederhole das experiment
zusammen mit den anderen gewürzen komme
ich jetzt auf ein gramm salz pro 100
gramm tomaten sauce und es schmeckt
wirklich ganz passabel zuletzt benutze
ich frische kräuter und frisches knobi
speziell 0,6 gramm
als trainer auf die 100 gramm beim
selbst kochen benutzt man zumindest bei
tomatensoße deutlich weniger salz und
viel besser schmeckt eigentlich auch was
ist also mein fazit für euch selbst
kochen ist immer gesünder nicht nur was
als betrifft aber falls das nicht
möglich sein sollte dann schau doch ab
und zu mal auf die nährwerttabellen
drauf damit sie überhaupt eine
vorstellung davon kriegt was ihr am tag
so zurecht hinzu kommt dass bei allen
ernährungsthemen ganz viele individuelle
faktoren eine rolle spielen ich werde
jetzt zum beispiel nicht so viel salz
brauchen wie ein zwei-meter-mann oder
ein sportler wird mehr natrium brauchen
als eine couch potato aber vor allem ist
geschmack nachgewiesenermaßen
gewöhnungssache das heißt wenn ihr
wirklich euren salzkonsum zurück fahren
wollt dann schafft ihr das mit genug
geduld und zeit also wie sieht's bei
euch auch sei die richtige salz monster
oder fällt es leicht darauf zu
verzichten und hat dieses video
irgendwas eurer meinung geändert
schreibe es in die kommentare wir sehen
uns nächsten donnerstag bis dahin bleibt
sicher ich liebe chips du deswegen kaufe
ich mir auch nie welche deswegen benutze
ich tipps als videoclips auch so oft es
geht achtet mal drauf ich habe sehr oft
chips in meinen videos weil dann ist es
ja fürs video was soll man machen